[موسيقى]
أجنبي
هو كيف يكسب أحمد البالغ من العمر 22 عامًا لقمة
العيش ، وعادة ما يغوص في القمامة لبيع
الخردة للقائمين بإعادة التدوير ،
لكن هذه هي الطريقة التي
يطعم بها اللاجئ السوري عائلته حرفيًا
[موسيقى]
إنه رمضان والعديد من سكان
العاصمة اللبنانية بيروت يصومون من الفجر
حتى الغسق
عادة ما يتطلع الناس إلى قضاء ليلة في الليل
إذا كان هناك تفكير في تناول وجبة في نهاية اليوم
هذا العام ، حيث يتفشى انعدام الأمن الغذائي ،
مما يضطر الكثيرين
لأول مرة
إلى التسول من المحتمل أن يكون 50 في المائة منهم
تحت خط الفقر
يكافحون من أجل الحفاظ على  سقف فوق رؤوسهم
قبل عامين ، كان راتب
علي يعادل
300 شهريًا بما يكفي للحصول عليه
الآن على الرغم من أن هذا الراتب نفسه
يزيد قليلاً عن 37 دولارًا في اليوم
[موسيقى]
في نفس الوقت الذي ارتفع فيه سعر الطعام بشكل
كبير  ما يصل إلى 350
في عام واحد في الأسبوع الأول من رمضان
وحده ،
فإن تكلفة الأسرة النموذجية المكونة من خمسة أفراد
إذا
قفزت ما يقرب من الربع ،
هذا هو آخر أموالهم 4000
لتر
بقيمة  العملة
التي انخفضت بمقدار 90
سنتًا ، أصبحت الآن تساوي أقل من 50 سنتًا
قبل عامين ، وكان من الممكن أن تساوي
ما يقرب من ثلاثة دولارات
ثلاثة أضعاف رواتبهم اليومية اليوم ،
أما بقية أجورهم الليلية ، إذا كانت وجبة الطعام
تأتي من التبرعات ،
فقد انضمت قطاعات واسعة من المجتمع اللبناني إلى
الفقراء الجدد في البلاد
يستمتعون بملذات بيروت الصغيرة الآن
مثل أحمد ، إنهم يختبرون
شيئًا لم يسبق لهم الشعور
بالخزي عليه من قبل
لأن الله يسقط الناس
يفطرون.
يبدأ مرة أخرى
غدا